A graduate of Sydney Oxford and a stray and National University she joined the Senate department in Dante ninety
and occupied saying your perceived Ramin management roles before being appointed Deputy Clarke in two thousand
and five.
The parliamentary interests include powers privileges and immunities of Parliament and alleged to the process.
She is the editor of the straw and Senate practice two thousand and twelve
and the annotated standing orders of the astray and Senate two thousand
and nine other interests include literature history and travel topic to die is going to be a strike as Magna Carta.
And I would ask you to welcome him. Well thank you very much and good morning everybody.
It's a pleasure to be here in sunny Sydney after a fairly cool start the small inning.
I acknowledge and indorse the early knowledge man of country
and also thank the State Law of Three of New South Wales the history Council of New South Wales
and the Magna Carta Committee of the Rule of Law Institute for the symposium today.
Now it was Rupert broke who died one hundred years ago this year who said that history repeats itself.
Historians repaid one another.
For what I have to say this morning was very heavily on work done by Professor Nicholas Vincent Professor medieval
history at the University of East Anglia who is a renowned expert on Magna Carta.
I'm no such expert
but I'm here to tell you about a document that I have shared premises with for the past twenty five years.
Because it's not widely known that a stranger has one of the original exemplification of an early issue of Magna Carta.
In other words a copy that was made at the time of issue for promulgating. And throughout the country.
It dates from twelve ninety seven and was issued by Ed with the first
and as we've heard from Professor cadre based on the twelve twenty five text which differed in many important respects
from the original twelve fifteen charter.
So striking is copies a very rare treasure that there are only twenty three
or twenty four such exemplification surviving from the thirteenth century from the issues up to thirteen hundred
and the most recent one was discovered only this year and of course great Hartmann to munch the Magna Carta scholars.
Are only two of these rare things held outside the United Kingdom the other ones in private ownership in the United.
States but it's on permanent display in the National Archives in Washington D.C.
Now let me start by saying that a strenuous Magna Carta belongs to the Commonwealth Parliament is on permanent display
in Parliament House Canberra having been moved there in ninety nine from all Parliament House where it had been on
display for most of the time since nineteen sixty one.
Now that seems like a very simple part of history of effect
but behind these bold statements like tiles that intrigue me institutional rivalry the most incredible luck bit of
incompetence that matched up the desire of an impact as minor English public school with the nation
and institution building ambitions of.
An influential Cambra librarian of the fifty's and sixty's to acquire treasures for the new National Library.
Now Nicholas Vincent describes in wonderful child.
In an S I published in this little booklet which department published a couple of years ago.
Unless the first edition is sold out but excitingly the second edition revised
and expanded with a lot more material is in print at the printers as we speak and will be published shortly
and for details of that watch the Department of the Senate website for how you can get hold of a copy because it's a
delightful little booklet it's been the subject of the answers to Senate estimates hearings
and I'm sure the second edition will feature as well. Now that's all the advertising on going to do at the moment.
Let me just sketch the background
and fortunately Professor catteries covered quite a lot of this material so I want to have to repeat it.
But just remind you that the twelve fifteen charter of liberties was followed reasonably quickly after the death of
John by reaching issues in twelve sixteen and twelve seventeen and importantly
and I want you to remember it's the twelve seven attain issue of the charter which became known as Magna Carta had a
companion child the forest Chacha. And the two of them had a bit of a shared life.
Thereafter for a while and the first charter as we heard allowed common people into the king's forests
and gave them certain rights of. Having a pig's root around foot or whatever cetera.
That had been the prerogative of the monarch before then.
The twelve twenty five issue of of the charter issued when Henry the third reached eighteen years of age
when it was influential in becoming a foundation for.
Later issues and I'll move on quickly to the reign of Edward the First because by twelve ninety seven. The.
It with the first had suppressed and conquered whiles he was waging campaigns in France and Scotland
and he'd run out of money.
He's a talian bankers had gone bankrupt and therefore longer a source of income for him and he needed to raise funds.
He had few options other than to summon up Parliament and ask for supply.
To be funded from new levies and taxes but in return parliament demanded that the charters about the forest charter
and Magna Carta be reissued
and it went off to fight in France with these newly founded I mean he's And while he was away.
He's Regency Council issued the list.
Letters page and reciting the text of both the charters
and ordering their dispatched to the various parts of the various counties and for this purpose copies worldwide.
So it's one of those copies that's now in Canberra
and we know exactly which copy it is because like all good clocks I left their mark on the digital copies so that they
could be checked and we know that our copy of the Magna Carta. Was destined for the county of sorry.
The theory is that it was delivered to the sheriff of sorry who also happened to be the joint sheriff of the next door
county of Sussex and given into the custody of the nuns of these born Priory for safekeeping.
And it remained there we think until the dissolution of the monasteries in the sixteenth century.
Now whole collection of dock. Humans from the Priory then apparently passed into the hands of a family who.
Decades centuries later engage the services of a solicitor John. Mouche Louch.
From the town of Driton in some a sage a town about twenty miles from the King's School version.
Where our twelve ninety seven copy miraculously kind to live.
Now the documents that were originally in The Priory somehow ended up with this solicitor John Louch.
We don't know how his copy of the twelve ninety seven Magna Carta ended up in the King's School that no connection has
been discovered between latch and the school all the firm of solicitors and the school
but there is a local legend that says that.
The school's lawyers blunder mistakenly putting documents in the wrong box possibly returning to the school a document
that didn't belong to the school but was discovered this subsequently many years later.
We do not know what happened to the rest of Laotians men scripts because after he died his son donated them to the
British Museum.
Now the British Library
and the collection included importantly the sorry copy of the forrest chacha of twelve ninety seven.
So that companion child. We've got the twelve ninety seven.
Sorry Magna Carta the British Library Scott the twelve ninety seven forests chacha But even in the best of libraries
things can go wrong. And according to nickel. Vincent. Owing to a casual logging era.
And a five year to identify the forest charter as an original copy of dieting from twelve ninety seven.
The British Museum didn't quite appreciate what it had in its possession. So.
When the King's School in Bruton in need of some cash decided to offer its copy for Syal you know the British Museum
and said well how much will you give us
and the British Museum not realizing what it was looking at in relation to its our holdings said two to two
and a half thousand pounds.
School was pretty disappointed at that valuation went to Southern bees and saw the bee said least ten thousand pounds.
So the school commissioned the bees to sell the Magna Carta by Prophet. Tracy.
And to the British Library failure to identify the connection
and what it already had was really quite pivotal in the machinations that followed about the permissions needed to
export. The document when the time came. Those machinations are beautifully covered by Nicholas Vincent.
So I won't go into them here.
But we ended up with a situation where Harold white the librarian or I should actually show us.
This is it in its Ark kies which I'll tell you about a little in a minute. How or why the librarian. Located this and.
Arranged to buy it for an asking price of twelve and a half thousand pounds. STERLING.
Now in astronomy and pounds of the time this was about fifteen thousand six hundred pounds.
That's just a sum of money so I thought you know how do we make this comparable recognizable to something that we
recognise today. In other Sydney real estate prices.
So I consulted the Sydney Morning Herald for the fourteenth of June fifty two which was the date closest to the
anniversary and nine hundred fifty two was the year of purchase.
I found a very small number of properties in that price range.
You could buy a fine gentleman as residence on a large block on the no shore of the eastern suburbs.
Between about six and a half to twenty thousand pounds.
But people with fifteen thousand six hundred might have considered one of the following.
Exhibit one a two story residence in Moore
and got three reception rooms three bedrooms multiple bathrooms detached double garage lovely gardens such consular
officials all retired graziers sixteen thousand pounds. Exhibit two.
A stately bungalow in war a weight build with the best pre-war materials for reception rooms four bedrooms multiple
bathrooms detached double garage with econd. Artist landscape gardens tennis court Bush House saw and stone.
Ne aspect for fifteen thousand pounds
or Finally a Spanish style two story home in Clifton gardens with sweeping harbor views from all windows.
Lofty reception whole balcony staircase large lounge a dining room study staff quarters four bedrooms multiple
bathrooms terraced gardens and fish ponds impossible to build this prize. Fifteen thousand on. Often.
It other would while Magna Carta was bought for a very substantial sum.
It was not a fortune beyond imagination particularly for a national government even one counting its pennies so
carefully in a period of post.
Now the purchase as I mentioned was headed by a Harold watch parliamentary librarian from nineteen forty seven to
nineteen sixty seven.
But from its earliest days the parliamentary library was always a bit of a hybrid it was also a National Library.
And what therefore played a role the national component of the library was known as the Commonwealth National Library
and it was governed by overseen by a joint parliamentary committee comprising the larger committees of the house.
Which were empowered to make to get the for that purpose.
The committee encourage watch to pursue a determined collection policy with an eye on the ultimate separation of the
parliament she lobby from the National Library.
Now this actually happened as a result of legislation in nineteen sixty stepless Xing the National Library which moved
into new premises on the shores of the brand new like Burley Griffin in ninety six the ITE.
In the meantime White's magnificent purchase arrived in Australia and spent several years at C.S.I.
Our own premises being examined and scientists working out the best while conserving it
and they ended up building a crime glass case for it filled with gas and it's still in that.
It's due to be examined again. CERN.
And we'll see what happens to it then but in nine hundred fifty two
when the purchase was my there it was announced with great excitement
and met with great enthusiasm to the two houses of the parliament.
Prime Minister Menzies despite his efforts on the Communist Party dissolution Bill made a resulting tribute to Magna
Carta as the first charter of civil liberties the basis of the rule of law
and the precursor of democratic principles opposition leader Doc Rivers who we've also heard about Smalling referred to
the charters embodiment of the rule of law liberty and a hatred of the tree government.
He referred to as contemporary resonance in a world so recently asylum by totalitarianism bouts of the left in the Raj.
But it was said that president.
Sen Edward man who perhaps put his finger on Magna Carta has enduring significance and resonance. He said. This case.
Lee One great principle of the English Constitution of the present which is not a raid into the provisions of Magna
Carta. Now many of these were wrongly claimed to flow from Magna Carta.
But we cannot afford to underestimate the value of traditional interpretations whether they were historically well
founded
or real founders the greatness of Magna Carta lies not so much in what it was to its frame as in twelve fifteen.
As in what it afterwards became to the political leaders to the judges and lawyers
and to the entire mass of the men of England of the astray
and constitution in body as it does the principles of British liberty
and representative government is in that sense a true lineal descendant of the greit charter.
I think if he'd been alive to see the castle no doubt he would have preferred to. Five of the Magna Carta as well.
So in not in sixty one Magna Carta merged from the ministrations of the scientists
and was put on what everyone except old White thought of as a permanent display in King's House between the two
chambers
and director of the British Museum at the time Sir Frank Francis the chairman of the National Lottery Council said
Grenfell inspecting the magnet in things hole of Parliament House. But over the winter recess in nineteen sixty eight.
Magna Carta disappeared from King's hole.
And when the houses resumed there was great consternation questions were asked in the House
and the speaker rather apologetically explained that doubts about the iron ship the document.
By the parliament and he in the president of the Senate had accepted that temporary custody and solve it
and that it really begun bought for the National Library which now had its spanking brand new building to which Magna
Carta had removed for the winter recess.
He did hint that as being overseas at the time it was really the Senate president that was responsible for the
difference.
Plusa well had wash the librarian was lambasted in the houses for spiriting the Magna Carta away with parliamentary
approval. How could it possibly have been bought by an institution that didn't even exist at the time of the purchase.
Member Hindmarsh Claude.
Cameron in a fiery adjournments space age more than one hundred members
and senators signed a petition for the return of the Magna Carta to Parliament House Prime Minister Gordon said nothing
to do with me it's a matter for the presiding offices
and in the Senate opposition leader Lionel Murphy asked the Senate president Marlin to accept the petition as a firm
expression of the desire of the Senate to have the document returned.
Now President McMullan agreed to act this in turn cause some senators to be quite concerned that they are DIA that the
president would contemplate acting in his official capacity on the basis of an informal education.
So Senator Ridge with is brought forward a motion on the evening of the twenty seventh of November nineteenth sixty
eight to the effect that in the Senate's opinion. The best place for Magna Carta to reside was in the National Library.
This was done he said to test the will of the Senate in a formal way to allow the voices of the minority to be heard
and to ensure that the president
when he acted would be doing so in accordance with the wishes of a majority of the Senate.
In other words he was concerned that due process for which Magna Carta was saying now is a guarantee he should provide
the Senate a lot of Murphy moved an amendment to the motion to admit National Library
and substitute Parliament House and over the next.
Well again nothing changes over the next hour and a half the senators argue the toss between the two.
Despite the funds coming from the Prime Minister's Department with I had been earmarked for purchases for the new
National Library a mere technicality. Senator Murphy.
That parliament had actually appropriated the funds to buy a document for display in Parliament House where it could be
seen by hundreds of thousands of visitors each year on like a library place of dollars ship research and quietness.
Not a place for visitors to be tramping around he said now the technicalities of ownership are interesting
and the source of the farms all very well but of course the real play was to emotion
and the rightful place of documents as iconic as Magna Carta in Parliament House.
I believe that Parliament is the voice of the people parliament is the most precious thing in our way of life
and it stems initially from the Magna Carta said Senator Anderson in arguing for the return of the document Senator
Rand leader of the government in the Senate. And despite the legal niceties.
About the ship the Senate voted overwhelmingly to express its view that Magna Carta the return to Parliament House.
How would one knew when he was basin.
So he relinquished custody of the art affect the precious treasure was returned to Kings hole where it was referred to
occasionally in debates. For example in one thousand nine hundred six in the Australian card bill device there were.
Exhortations of Magna Carta sitting out there in members' hole
and in ninety ninety eight it was moved up to the new Parliament House in the equivalent place to members hole in the
Old Parliament House the legal niceties of our ship were result. She'll be placed here in two thousand and five by.
A deed signed by the then director general of the National Library and.
That then secretary of the department of Parliamentary Services transferring both are in a ship
and custody to the power amount of the Commonwealth of Australia. And in two thousand and ten.
It moved into its current position as part of an exhibition on the law making process.
It had been housed in a fairly D.M.
Little cubby in Memphis hole where many people walked past it
and didn't realise what it was in the next little cubby there was the title that Queen Victoria signed the Constitution
act on that cubby on the other side had.
The petitions and there was another copy with our Can't remember what's what was in there but in two thousand
and ten we brought it more into prominence and it's currently in a very visible place. Just to give you.
I did promise non-revenue ties in but that part of the exhibition is online and you can view it that that address.
So to conclude the Magna Carta is a resting quality saw perhaps in the words of the Council it's vibe.
Both physical and emotional because it's a beautiful document
and as beautiful as this rep reproduction is the twelve ninety seven copy in Canberra is quite glorious.
That physical and emotional element continue to attract generations of visitors to Parliament House
and of course this eight hundredth anniversary of the original ceiling of twelve fifteen charter provides a great
opportunity to excite new generations about its significance. Thank you very much. Well thank you.
Rosemary for that that wonderful story that intriguing story and I'm sure they'll be questions
and we do have a bit of time for them. So any questions. Planes are excellent.
Well it's still in perfect working order. It is to be inspected and possibly possibly opened and I guess replaced.
You know experts consulted on technologies that would be appropriate. Today. But what your father did in the fifty's.
I think was designed to last for many many years
and it certainly has given that that document was lying around in cupboards
and goodness knows where of the many centuries what sort of condition was already in when it arrived here
and was so much restoration work required.
Look that it wasn't it wasn't just floating around the school again legend has it that it was found in a desk
but I think it was you know fairly well protected and it was actually in quite good condition.
This is an essay in this little book by sorry but the former director of odd services home
and house who is now the curator of manuscripts at the National Library has written about the details of its
conservation and the work that had to be done and I would be happy to give you that reference it will come.
Second Edition. It will be it. It'll be a great price ten dollars and it's still there.
This is actually this one has been the best seller of the parliament house shop.
Now that I say something about the rest of the country.
Rosemary's mentioned there are two originals of the Magna Carta outside of England
and she's told you to reflect story of Australia's. I just thought you might be interested to complete the picture.
In the other one which is in the United States of America which Rosemary mentioned.
It was provided by the Brudenell family of park in Northamptonshire here in nineteen eighty three.
And it was purchased by Ross Perot's you might remember him a presidential candidate at one stage in the United States
in one thousand nine hundred three for one point five million dollars. It's another twelve ninety seven document.
In two thousand and seven there are solved it.
So an entrepreneur industrialist what have you called David Rubenstein in the United States.
Who has since gifted it to the US National Archives where Rosemarie mentioned it is now held
and having purchased it for one point five million dollars Ross Perot sold it for twenty one point three million
dollars And just to complete that story even though I promised no more advertising.
David Rubenstein has actually done a little essay for all the second edition on on the purchase.
I was looking at that manuscript in a straight yes they obviously became aware of it some point.
Yes I did because you know imagine they could have just said Well sorry that's House.
It's it was part of the deed of gift from the louts family or even know that can't be exported it's us
and Nicholas Prince and goes into those exciting. Negotiations in his he says.